この動画はね、 まあ、 俺のねマミーの、  友達かな？
知り合いの、 娘さんか、 息子さんに向けてゆってくれってゆう事をその
娘さん息子さんのお母さん伝えで、 俺のマミーに行って
で、 俺のマミーが LINEで俺に 「言いなさい」 と、ゆわれたってゆう流れでございます。
俺の、 マミーの知り合いの、 娘さん、息子さん？  見てるかい？
いつもありが ｔ・・・
と言う訳で今回は、まちょっと軽く  お話で御座います。
ま、 タイトルにもある通りですね、
勉強のやる気が出ない って子が多い、 受験中にも関わらずね？
今、ちょうど多分あれだよね？
今、 多 分夏休み前の 定期テストをやってる 人　とかやった人
やる前の人ぐらいの人　が多分いると思うんですけども、
まあ、ひとまず このテストが終わったら夏休みでございます。みんな、 夏休みへようこそ！
甘い事言ってんじゃねぇ
受験生！大事なのはここからです
夏休みに入ってからが、  受験生はホントに勝負なので
まあ、皆さん頑張ってくださいってゆうわけで
あの、なんてゆわれてるかってゆと、なんてゆわれてんだっけな
取りあえずね、 その子ども達の 勉強のやる気をこう、 起こさせろ!    みたいな事をゆわれたので
僕なりにちょっと、 僕がどうやってね勉強してたって事を、 今回教えようと思います
良かったら是非、 聞いてください
わたくし、はじめしゃちょーぶっちゃけた話
馬鹿でございます
やや天才だけどね、　天才だよ？　天才だよ？　天才ですけども、
ま、学生と言うその　囲いのコミニュティーの中では馬鹿でした
なので、　もう間違いもしますし　失敗だらけなんですけれども
何とか今も元気に生きて居ります
で、今からゆう話は、僕が凄い人間だからって話じゃなくて
誰でもできるような話でございます
そう言う事でなんか　僕自身が特別だった　って訳じゃ無いってゆう事で、　まず聞いてください
はじめ流　受験勉強の極意　とゆうものを教えようと思います。
で、これはですね、えと、注意事項として先ず、受験生以外でも使えるとは思います
今多分ね　勉強する気が無い人って凄い多いと思うんすよ
もう誘惑が大過ぎ
スマホ、ゲーム、
スマホ、ゲーム、スマホ、ゲーム、スマホ、スマホ、スマホ、スマ・・・
誘惑ををいかに断ち切って勉強するかってのが大事だと思います
僕がどんな気持ちで勉強してたかってゆうのをちょっと皆さんにお伝えしようと思います
で、　もう一つ、　注意事項として、　これが正しい方法とは限りません
皆それぞれ、　そのねヤル気の出しかたってゆうのが有るので、
これはあくまで　僕はこう考えながらやってたよ、　ってゆう考えの一つにすぎないので　これが正しいって事もないし
人それぞれ、その、自分が頑張れるね、心の持ちようってゆうﾔﾂが有るので、
まあ、あくまで参考までに、　四つあるんですけど僕はこの四つを、　心に叩き込んで受験勉強を乗り切ったっ　とゆう話でございます
勉強のやる気が出ない人、　受験勉強が近い人、　良かったら、きいてみてください
では、行こ！
一つ目。　学校は嫌い。　バシッと来ました
はい、当に名前の通りです。
僕、実は学校があんまり好きではありません。
先生が怖いです。集団で動くのが好きではありません。
色んな理由があって、　僕実 はそんなに学校が好きじゃなくて、　むしろどっちかってゆうと嫌いです
なんで 部活引退した後 受験勉強中になるんですけども
もう基本的に僕はもう あれですよ
もう授業が終わったら走って帰ってました  学校から
居る意味がないんで。
もう学校は ｲやｲやルーティーン作業みたいな感じで サラーっと行ってました
でもね、 先生方はちゃんと準備して居てくれてるんですよ。 その、 受験勉強用に向けた補習とかさ
放課後のなんか授業とか準備してくれてるんですけども
僕は一切出ませんでした。 出る意味を感じなかったです。
あ！僕はね？、僕の話ですからね
僕は出る意味が感じなかったです。
え、 なぜかと言いますと、 要するに同じ偏差値、 同じレベルの生徒たちが集まってる訳じゃないですか、  その学校にはね？
で、 そいつ達で 同じ授業を受けて  同じ勉強の仕方をしてても、 上には登れないな と思いました。
受験勉強の敵 と言うのは 学校内だけじゃないんですよ。
もう、 全国の全員がねライバルなので、
同じレベルのやつら  と同じレベルの勉強を してても多分、  このレベルから上には行けないな と思ったので
補習の授業は一切無視して全部出ず、僕はひたすら自己流で勉強しておりました、という話でございます
まあ、それで成績が上がるか上がらないかは、内容と掛けた時間次第でございます
集団行動、あんまり好きじゃなかったですね
二つめ！　１人でやりましょう。受験勉強ね
勉強は一人でやる物です。助け合いなんて必要ないです。全員敵です。
何か友達と協力し合ってやってた人も居たんですけども
もしさ、それさ、なに？片方が成績上がって片方が成績落ちちゃったりしたら、なんかヤな気持ちになりそうだな、っとか１人でこっそり思てて
部活引退してからの受験期間中はもう学校でも、全てにおいて基本的に独りで行動しておりました。
いや、淋しかったけれど、それくらいしないと誘惑に負けちゃうんですよね。
学校に居る時もなるべくね、こう１人でこうずっと参考書とか読んでました。
懐かしいなぁ、それぐらいの覚悟で僕は勉強をしておりました。
ま、取りあえず一人でやるのはすごいモチベーションになります、僕は
誰も目も気にしなくていい、独りで好きなだけ勉強をしていました。
１人でやれってゆう話なんですけど、果たして僕は何処で勉強をしていたか。
学校は皆でﾀﾑﾛしててなんか気分悪いから嫌だった。
家では誘惑が多すぎて無理
僕は実はずっと図書館で勉強しておりました。
学校終わったらすぐ図書館に行って無言で一人で黙々と勉強してました
三っつめ！　頑張っているのは内緒にしましょう
今は別ですけど、高校の時はなんか頑張ってるのがね、ちょっと恥ずかしい事だと思ってて
頑張ってるのがすごい なんか 馬鹿らしいというか、 頑張って結果が出なかった時が  すげーカッコ悪いなと  思ってて
ま、 そういうのも有ってですね多分、 頑張ってる自分ってゆうのを  なんか誰かに見られたくなかったのもあるし、
それで点数が上がらなかったってゆうのが誰かに見られてもｽｺﾞｲ嫌だし、頑張ってるのは僕、ずっと内緒にしてました。
皆で頑張って一緒に勉強してたのに、 自分だけ成績が上がってなかったらｽｺﾞｲ恥ずかしい思いをするな、 と思ってて。
これはもう多分僕の心が弱かっただけです
誰にも言ってねーな多分。
頑張ったのに失敗するっゆうてのもすごい嫌だったので、  頑張ってるのは僕は内緒にしてました。
周りの目を気にせず頑張る為にと言う意味で
そして最後、四つ目です
これは、僕が何でシャーペンが好きかゆうのにｽｺﾞｲ由来します。
頑張ってるのは内緒だし、誰も気づいてないとは思うんですけども、シャーペンだけは、いつも、見てくれてます
今ちょっと頭おかしい人かと思ったっしょ？
でも実際そうなんっすよ
いや、それも何か頭おかしい・・・
１人でずっと勉強してたり、  なんか頑張ってるっての   誰にも言わなかったら、  うまく行かなかったとき、 それこそ何にも残らないなと思う訳ですよ
勉強してる自分を誰も知らないからさ
うまくいかなかったら、
うまく行かなかったら  みんなそれが当たり前見たいな目で  見て来るくるだろうし、
１人で勉強してると、 これが本当に正しいのかｽｺﾞｲ不安になることも有るとは思います
結果に繋がらない時もあるし、 そういう時も凄い孤独でなんかね、 辛いって  思う時もあると思います。
僕も有りました。  有ったんですけども勉強するとき 、辛かったし、 誰も見てくれてないし、 自分の頑張りは誰も知ってないと思うんですけども、
いつも、 君の手元には、 シャーペンが居ると思います。
いや、マジな話ね。
そう  多分だから俺シャーペン好きなんだろうね？
１人で勉強してる訳なんですけども、必ず手元には仲間が１人居ます。
だーれも見てないし、だーれも自分がどれだけ勉強したかって事も知ってないと思うんですけど
シャーペンだけは・・・
勉強はしてる時は、どんな時でも・・・常に
頑張ってる自分を見てくれてると思います
シャーペンにものすごい情熱とか   愛情がるのは多分、  多分受験中にね  シャーペンに向かって 心でこう語りかけてた自分が  居たのが多分原因だと思います。
かなりやべー人だな
かなりヤベー人だ!!
かなりヤベー人なんですけども、まあ、お守りみたいなもんでしょ
この、はじめ流受験勉強の極意はとても孤独で辛いものです
辛い物なんですけども、シャーペンだけはずっとどれだけ頑張ってくれたかを見てくれて
このシャーペンを信じて僕は受験に行きました
これ本当に参考になるのかな
なるべく カッコイイ自分で 最高のゴールに行きたいな、 と思って、 こういう勉強法になりました。
はい、という感じでございます。
これがね、参考になるかどうか僕は分んないんですけど、受験生の皆さん
受験は夏がマジで勝負でございます。
この方法が参考になるか分んないんですけども、受験勉強は自分との闘い!
自分に打ち勝って全国のみんなをぶっ倒してください。
仲良しこよしの勉強ではありません。高い点数を取った人が合格します。
受験生の皆さんが笑顔で春を迎えられるように応援しております。
じゃな！
マミー？　これでいいかい？